pour être honnête on avait aucun critère
spécifique pendant le casting on voulait
juste trouver la meilleure personne pour
le rôle on a regardé toutes les ethnies
on voulait juste trouver la personne qui
serait la meilleure
et elle a placé la barre tellement haut
tellement tôt
sa voix est vraiment extraordinaire et
elle a beaucoup de profondeur de passion
de force et aussi de joie
ça voilà ça typiquement ça ça me rend
fou ils ont pris la meilleure c'est tout
ferme ta gueule non mais c'est tout
c'est un truc de ouf non mais les mecs
qui viennent poser la question de quoi
tu parles c'est un truc de ouf non mais
c'est vrai c'est c'est
on marche sur la tête il fait ce qu'il
veut il a pris la meilleure et c'est
aussi bien d'avoir mis une personne de
couleur il faut le dire moi moi je
rentre même pas là-dedans moi
c'est bien aussi parce que les
personnages de dessins animés qui date
de l'autre du siècle dernier avait des
héros qui sont pour la plupart blanc à
part des personnages très caricaturaux
parce que c'est la meilleure
moi je ne supporte plus ce truc aussi de
discrimination positif pour moi c'est la
plus grosse forme de racisme
je me pose pas la question je me dis
c'est la meilleure c'est pas la
meilleure voilà
avant il y avait que des blancs qui
étaient stars de dessins animés
tu devrais être un petit peu dans
l'humidité comme moi oui moi je vais
vous décevoir mais je suis totalement
d'accord avec Guillaume et en fait
lui aussi mais
tu es toujours en fait tu es toujours
dans le mauvais sens tu prends toujours
le périph à contre-courant non mais sans
déconner c'est extraordinaire qu'elle
soit noire parce qu'elle est noire et de
la part de Disney qui a souvent été très
en retard mais nous étions là c'est
formidable
ce que tu dis c'est la Pallice en fait
mais non c'est génial qu'elle soit noire
parce que rien ne vous dit qu'au départ
la petite sirène n'était pas noir enfin
juste la meilleure
toi toi tu sais quoi c'est en fait tu
dis toujours ce qu'il faut pas dire le
problème c'est important
ils sont là parce qu'ils sont morts
moi j'ai adoré l'application du
réalisateur mais c'était la meilleure
c'est la meilleure c'est moi qui
m'énerve c'est qu'on pose la question et
la question la réponse elle est dans le
truc pourquoi vous l'avez pris parce que
c'est la meilleure il a raison c'est
tout il s'en sert de casting ils ont vu
plein de gens ben c'était la meilleure
c'est bon stop Arsène Lupin
Omar Sy parce que c'était le meilleur
exactement
parce que votre discours discrédit
complètement son talent en fait
mais non mais c'est vrai
on va voir tes copains à la sortie de là
c'est pas mes copains c'est pas mes
copains mais les copains ça fait très
bien que le réalisateur il est obligé il
est obligé de dire ça parce qu'il veut
être conforme dans la bien-pensance que
vous avez essayé
non mais vous savez très bien
réalisateur il a pris la meilleure et
s'il devait prendre le meilleur et tu
aurais pas pris voilà je suis pas noir
merci
c'est cool
que Disney a fait au noir c'est terrible
donc là c'est un vrai évolution vous
essayez de minimiser
[Applaudissements]
le monde change bravo à Disney d'avoir
pris la meilleure ils n'ont pas comme
Gilles Verdez on veut toujours faire
voilà c'est insupportable je vais te
dire c'est toi qui qui l'a créé c'est
c'est des discours comme ça qui créent
des différents
Laponie la question moi je dis faut même
pas poser la question voilà
en plus moi c'est celui qui pose la
question